ich bin bei fragen bei der perfekte apa
red das ist ja fast schon so wie die
richtige musik also will er das richtige
musik machen oder wie ich finde das
passt einfach nicht so wirklich kommen
zu einigen von euch bestimmt mitbekommen
haben sind in letzter zeit zwei sänger
aus gekommen war lange still in einer
gewissen werke von youtube der maschine
hatte ich nicht so hoch geladen hatte
ewig nicht hochgeladen patrick auch fast
alles monatelang nicht hoch bleiben aber
jetzt kam wieder was andernfalls hätten
sich abgesprochen wie schon heute mal
rein in so hell von patrick und yamaha
baby von operator dem ist normal karte
tatsächlich einen monat lang nix
hochgeladen dann kam jetzt eben lohan
und diese blau roten balken die ihr
unter den fachmessen sie stehen für das
leih cloud sodass gleich rot verhältnis
57.000 gleich zu 44.000 dislike das ist
schwanger ist glaube ich für krieg
tatsächlich nicht so gut
also sagen die anfangs sehr aufwendig
produziert die shows sind echt schön
damit sie wirklich mühe gegeben es hat
auch so gewissen weit muss man sagen
aber so rein stimmlich das bisschen dünn
finde ich ja ich weiß es nicht leute ich
will es mal ganz ehrlich bei der dinge
bei diesem lied den eindruck dass er so
eine gewisse ordentliche grundtendenz
hat okay also die allgemeine richtung
stimmt formal aber die umsetzung ist
irgendwie so ich weiß nicht findet ihr
gewissen lustlos gemacht das kommt bei
mir so als hätte man da nicht wirklich
bock gehabt hat so ein bisschen ja
missionieren da also ungefähr
das liegt vielleicht nicht so weit dass
ich katastrophal scheiße aber so
deutlich muss seinen garten 45 prozent
ist schon ein bisschen hart oder die
kommentar schreibt meine ksm
missgeburten accounts schreiben was von
ihr verantwortete wusste der smi kinder
ihr schreibt eine erste tracks und einem
youtuber de recht musikalisch ist einer
der stärksten youtuber track
da gibt's natürlich auch immer die leute
die versuchen so fit zu sein weil die
haben gehört machen wir alle mit und
schreiben versucht zu singen und dabei
im archiv im mak strände und kästen in
irgendeiner anderen und da spielt sie
noch mal eine sex szene
kurzzusammenfassung ganz nette idee
schönes video eigentlich aber sogar ein
bisschen lustlos auf der anderen seite
haben natürlich apparat mit yamaha baby
wurde vor zwei tagen hochgeladen ist
immer noch im trend auf platz vier und
hat auch recht viele klicks gemacht zwei
millionen klicks aber auch bombing viele
discs 205.000 136.000 bis gleixner erste
was auffällt er richtig krass sein rad
kamera und bones ist schon extrem nah an
den teils plastikding als auch niemand
bei uns im zielgebiet überlaufen s2000
folge doch gleich viel kreativer zu den
fans ich krieg bedeute verarschen und
verschlossen jetzt will der musik machen
wir damit geld machen kann wird machen
die jungs wurde länder das machen wir
fragen nur tätig du hast du bist eben
viele sitzen ja das vielleicht auch
nicht leute scheinbar so die auffassung
in deutschland das upgrade der fall den
hit geändert hat mir die alle habibi und
so hell angeblich nicht bedeuten soll
aber ich finde die al abidi auch
überhaupt nicht gut dass es genauso nur
15 wendig bisschen besser als so hell
deswegen kann ich schon verstehen aber
es vielleicht gar nichts
also ich glaube ich dass einige von euch
kennen die er ab kamera ich versuche
jetzt bewusst gemeint zu sein also leute
nicht so gefährlich zu sein findet das
wirkt einfach wie bei unseren rat ein
bisschen schlechter bestellt was ich
meine diese art und weise den song zu
machen
ich finde wirklich vielleicht nicht die
kommentare leute allerdings lackiert ist
unnötig war war liegt nicht angehört das
lied ist richtig gut besser als bei
wagen nämlich gar nicht meine
wahrnehmung der ganzen sache als upgrade
ist auf youtube dafür da um songs zu
machen die einfach ein bisschen scheiße
wenn aber scheiterte in einer art und
weise dass er mich provozieren dass die
irgendwie lustig sind dass man jobs war
katrina warten ich bin papa fragen bei
der perfekte apa red
das ist ja fast schon so wie die
richtige musik also wenn die richtige
musik machen oder wie ich finde das
passt einfach nicht so wirklich ich
finde das passt einfach nicht so
wirklich weil man merkt dass der song
wird die ernst gemeinde nicht wie man
jetzt ernst gemeint ok allah hat wie wir
es ernst gemeint aber das passt nicht
länger der kann nicht ernst gemeinte
songs machen in meinen augen zumindest
jetzt noch ein extra schreibt oder
wirklich schlecht bin beeindruckt und
salz kopf beschreibt genau derselbe müll
wie immer
exakt heftig schreibt dazu ganz objektiv
und nur bezogen und die musik bis heute
red kein song veröffentlicht der nicht
absolut geklaut ist kippt nicht jetzt
nicht jetzt von casey ab und verschwand
[Musik]
die parallelen sieht man schon gemerkt
doch von der stimme her für geld am
rhein kommt von der corporate reinkommt
[Musik]
ich bin upgrade ist nicht der typ im
ernst dass songs zu machen der kann
lustige provokante sonst machen wir aber
wagen aber so ernste musik in meinen
augen nicht das war's für heute zwischen
grimma so ein kleines päckchen kommentar
analyse video vielleicht nicht morgen
wieder einen account ein nettes video